ceux qui sont restés dans le camp
Je ne sais pas s'ils sont vivants ou non, mais ils sont
Je veux être la voix de quelqu'un qui a quitté le camp
Je me souviens de 67 personnes
alors j'ai écrit leurs noms sur
C'est l'âge qu'il a
quelle est la faute ici et la fille dont le dac
aime elle possède
ici c'est écrit ici jalilova
gullba dur terroriste a aidé
terroriste, c'est le papier qu'ils voulaient
donc j'ai mis la peinture ici
ici, je suis exactement le même appareil photo ici, c'était dans
cette année 3 mois 10 jours
puis les filles noires viennent de l'interrogatoire
met le sac pour l'interrogatoire puis à partir de là
compte pour 24 heures deux 72 heures d'interrogatoire
ne vient qu'ils sont tous battus sur la tête
partout toutes les bosses ont du sang facile à couler
le lendemain le sac noir est de nouveau dans le département
emmené pour interrogatoire je n'y crois plus
sous-sol et dans la rue et là tu cries un peu
veut quelque chose ils me font quelque chose du tout
Je ne peux pas entendre quoi que ce soit d'installé est venu à moi
a commencé à piquer
Je lui ai dit gulya live maman non
tu n'as pas de soeurs en quelque sorte
mashka se retourne il m'a battu violemment
dit quelque chose comme ma mère ressemble
sois-tu sur tu regardes qui tu es sur qui
similaire
[musique]
Le nouveau Gurov chinois a été abattu
beaucoup de gens ont été tués
chars tués et après ça a commencé
détenir egorov a commencé le
[musique]